salut aujourd'hui je vais faire une
expérience particulièrement intéressante
sur la thématique de l'alcool il y aura
avec moi audrey pierrot ludovic bifani
fiq unis no arias durant une semaine je
leur ai demandé quelque chose de simple
mais qu'ils n'ont pourtant jamais fait
au cours de leur vie c'est à dire notés
sur un papier chaque verre d'alcool
qu'ils ont consommé évidemment pour que
cette expérience fonctionnent ils ne
devaient pas augmenter ou diminuer leur
consommation naturel merci d'ailleurs à
alcoolinfoservice qui nous permet de
réaliser cette vidéo la première étape
c'est que mes invités bon pour la
première fois de leur vie voir devant
eux en une seule fois en un seul coup
tous les verres d'alcool qu'ils ont
consommé en une semaine et je peux vous
dire que ça peut surprendre on va
ensuite savoir comment et pourquoi
chacun de ces verts ont été consommés et
vous allez voir que les réponses sont
parfois surprenantes petite précision
évidemment personne n'est là pour se
juger ou pour juger les autres ces
fantômes bienveillants s'il s'agit
vraiment d'une expérience passionnante
pour essayer de comprendre nos
consommations et aussi dans un sens pour
mieux comprendre la relation entre nos
cerveaux l'alcool est notre manière d'en
boire ça va être vraiment passionnant et
ça commence maintenant et c'est le
moment d'accueillir nos quatre invités
audrey pierrot ludovic b est-ce que tu
as une lettre dans sa mini noah rial et
fanny flic
déjà en vrai merci d'être là merci
beaucoup d'avoir assuré sept semaines en
jouant le jeu
on commence par toi audrey est ce que tu
peux essayer de te remémorer tous les
verts que tu as bu cette semaine il faut
savoir que c'était la semaine de mon
anniversaire donc on voit des gens donc
je n'ai vu personne d'accord donc je
n'ai vu vraiment personne rapport à la
situation de ma vie
du coup lundi rien le mardi 1 vers le
mercredi bojan shell de petit cocktail
très bien le jeu dit rien le vendredi 20
soins du visage mousse apéritif et là je
me suis ouvert une petite bière le
samedi certainement un verre de vin et
le dimanche mimosa le matin au quai au
brunch au brunch du matin d'accord ninon
hargne away alors lundi niet mardi bière
ok je pense d'eux trois bières mercredi
et jeudi rien et c'est vendredi que
vraiment la bascule ce pote qui a un bar
me dit viens on va passer un moment
ensemble j'ai pris une bière j'ai
commencé à partir direct au tribunal
parce qu'en fait j'avais oublié mon
manteau que du coup je revenu prendre
une deuxième bière ça c'est sûr et puis
une troisième et c'est là que après ça a
été une soirée complexe attends tu sais
quoi ça ça m'intéresse de dire ne
détaille pu cette soirée là combien tu
penses avoir bu deux verres sur cette
soirée je ne ferai pas un tout pile
c'est certain
je dirais une vingtaine une bataille
donc c'est ce qui nous ferait 23 vert
sur la soirée car la semaine après j'ai
fait encore juste une bière ou deux
essais tête en vue magnifique lundi
combien de verres d'alcool de ou deux
publics petite soirée entre potes j'ai
commencé au cidre je pense que j'ai bu
j'ai pas trois quatre ter de sid ensuite
j'irai unique de bière et à la fin petit
petit liqueur québécoise le lendemain
j'ai terminé une bouteille de vin que
j'avais ouvert dont personne ne voulait
bon je pense que j'ai bu de trois verres
dans cette bouteille la week end le
mardi soir ses week-ends à peine
après jacques redit jeudi vendredi rien
mais du coup moi je bois rarement
d'alcool tout seul c'est plus quand j'ai
des gens voient là l'occasion comme ta
maman absolument et du coup avec elle
quand est venu le week-end petit apéro
une de bière petit cocktail c'est tout
je prends ma rangée un rhum arrangé on
est allé comme la mémoire lui revient
ludo déjà donné ta semaine le
lundi mardi mercredi j'ai bu une bière
chaque jour
ouais le soir 19h petite bière vendredi
tu avais une soirée j'ai dû boire deux
verres de vin deux mojitos et de shooter
d'accord si verte ça me suffisait
d'ailleurs j'ai pas vu plus c'est
marrant parce que ça ça marche avec
n'importe quel des chiffres je but 27
verges me suffisait
et après j'ai pas vu le samedi mais j'ai
vu le dimanche que le dimanche j'avais
un repas de famille et j'ai dû boire
quatre verres de vin vous allez
découvrir tous les verts que vous avez
consommé chacun et chacune en une
semaine
je vous laisse vous retourner pour
découvrir votre consommation de la
semaine en une seule fois à les y
retourner vous et voici la consommation
de magnifiques et la consommation de
ninon
ici c'est oit ligue 2 cette fait quoi de
voir tout ce que tu as consommé dans la
semaine en une seule fois c'est vrai que
là on une fois ça fait ça fait beaucoup
coin oui typiquement je ne boirai pas
quoi et toi audrey qu'est ce que tu en
penses je trouve que ça va de toute
façon dans ma personnalité je modère les
choses en général après j'aurais pu
aussi nous pas du tout boire d'alcool
c'est ce qui me fait bizarre c'est en
termes de quantité tout est énorme alors
toi tu en a plein mais plein de petits
jeux été happé par le volume est content
de ce que j'ai vu il y en a pas mal
alors en train de préparer le terrain
pour compte en viendra à toi vas-y on
peut s'attendre je me rends compte que
je boitais petit verre mois par rapport
à elle si elle est semé des grandes
pinces alors que moi je fais des petites
rues non mais je revois ma soirée quoi
et je me dis qu'on passait une soirée
à boire boire oui moi ce que je me dis
c'est que tu abordes un point qui est
très intéressant c'est le côté rituel un
peu automatismes pas comme on l'a sur
cette ligne là où tu nous disais ben en
fait la bière c'est un rituel de soir je
pourrais voir autre chose ça m'irait
très bien oui allez tiens c'est 19h
finance et l'automobile c'est une autre
bâtisse et toi rappelle-moi les mais les
moments de consommation ah non il y
avait un petit bain rituel ah oui c'est
de là qu'elle vient sept villages et du
coup est ce que tu penses que ton ben
serait moins relaxant avec le décor elle
complètement le fait de boire de
l'alcool est soit de passer un moment
soit des plus relax et auquel ont
conscience que c'est moi qui mets
terminale et aille parce que je bois qui
détermine mon état c'est vrai mais c'est
pas forcément un chemin mental qu'on
fait tous comme ça spontanément mais
surtout selon l'âge que tu as aussi
c'est vrai parce que je te dis ça
aujourd'hui mais
il ya quelques années j'aurais pu aussi
avoir un autre discours
est ce que vous saviez qu'il ya des
repères de consommation d'alcool pour
limiter les risques sur notre santé en
vrai c'est ses repères ils sont
intéressants qui sont de 10 unités
d'alcool par semaine sachant qu'il faut
qu'il y en ait pas plus de deux par jour
et donc forcément des jours on boit pas
du tout toi t'as cramer les 10 je mets
un point d'honneur tu vas qui n'est pas
la fin sans pas le verre de tous les
soirs et c'est un peu par contre le
problème c'est que l inverse du coup
quand je vivais là j'y vais tg une
consommation en dents de scie un peu
alors la légende du verre de vin rouge
qui est bon pour la santé bah du coup tu
es avec moi surnageant ta question je me
disais bien aussi je les veux qu'ils
disent elles ont pu dedans est tout feu
et c'est vrai que on connaît très mal
l'alcool pire on connaît par contre
plein d'astuces dessus mais qu'ils ont
complètement fausse alors faisons
ensemble un petit tour des trois gros
idées reçues à ce sujet fun fact
d'ailleurs moi quand j'étais plus jeune
j'ai aussi cru à chacune d'entre elles
puisque tout le monde autour de moi
disait ça idées reçues numéro une et
c'est à froid tu bois un coup hein ça
réchauffe alors non la première chose
que fait l'alcool sur le corps c'est
justement l'inversé de baisser sa
température interne alors pourquoi on
croit linverse et bien une fois dans le
sang l'alcool dilate les vaisseaux
sanguins qui se trouve en fait de juste
en haut à proximité de la peau ce qui
donne une sensation presque une illusion
de chaleur mais qui est fausse car la
température interne du corps ne s'élève
pas idée rossier numéro 2 webb a au
moins moi j'ai vu qu'un seul verre de
vin c'est pas comme s'ils avaient pris
un verre avec un alcool fort peu importe
le nom de votre boisson c'est la même
molécule qu'on retrouve voici d'ailleurs
le tableau des équivalences alors qu'est
ce qu'on voit on y voit entre autres
qu'un verre de vin un apéritif anisé ou
une boisson un peu forte ou encore un
demi de bière ou encore à vin pétillant
contiennent tous la même quantité
d'alcool idées reçues numéro 3 une bonne
bière quand même hein ça désaltère alors
écouté que ce soit une bière ou un autre
verre d'alcool vous serez au contraire
déshydraté à chaque fois l'éthanol qui
est présent dans tous les verts
alcoolisées amène le corps à éliminer
son os donc d'où le fait que vous ayez
beaucoup envie d'aller et aux toilettes
d'ailleurs ce que l'on appelle la gueule
de bois est entre autres due à cette
déshydratation
alors là je vous demander de faire un
exercice un peu particulier je vais vous
demander d'enlever des verts et de vous
dire qu'elle vers vraiment objectivement
ça j'aurais pu me passer me servent à
rien ou j'aurais pu remplacer par un
verre d'eau on commence par toi lido
j'ai déjà ma petite idée mois déjà les
trois bières en fait c'est pas le côté
alcool qui m'intéressent là dedans ça
pourrait très bien pu être de l'alcool
je me ferais une menthe à l'eau à la
place et ça marche très bien ok ça me
fait mon repère donc là on commence
la soirée fifa mais là ça alors je peux
très bien toutes les enlever mais parce
que j'aime j'aime pas là bien c'est trop
et tu vois quand même des bières quoi du
coup lors de cette soirée c'est bien
parce que ton pote il arrive et il prend
de bien dans le frigo il ouvre par fuite
la donnes tu vois je préférerais un soda
mais comme lille ou la bière belle et tu
dis pas non tu dis ok on voit la
pressant social tout sous le regard de
l'autre tu dis non mais il va penser
quoi de moi une place laval sous les
noms mais moi une grenade j'ai pas envie
d'en de m'expliquer pendant trois heures
sans tabou exactement donc toi tu as une
bonne conscience de ce que tu as
consommer ce que tu as une bonne
conscience aussi de pourquoi tu
consommes sévère d'alcool ou c'est pas
des automatismes parce que je peux avoir
des comportements qui sont
addictif je suis très vigilante à ça
donc quand je consomme de l'alcool j'ai
conscience du fait que tu peux tomber
dans un schéma avec l'alcool je sais pas
quelque chose d'anodin c'est pas un
produit anodin donc ce premier
il est conservé celui du lendemain
effectivement jeu pourra retirer 1 parce
que il est vu sous l'impulsion du
premier c'est une envie très clair mais
c'est vrai que dans l'idée on pourrait
dire mais en fait en vrai si l'on a su
ça suffit la veille 1 pts suivi puis le
jour même famille at oui on refait la
semaine absolument qu'est-ce que tu
regardes qu'est-ce que tu gardes pas bah
en fait moi ça va être aussi facile j'ai
l'impression que si je fais une soirée
où je bois je me dis bon bah vu que je
vais boire ce soir va doubler la voix
l'ajout des vannes et donc du coup j'en
fait en vrai je pourrais d'en prendre
qu'1 de chaque tu vois j'ai bu trois
verres de cidre en vrai j'aurais pu en
voir qu'un masque en fait après je
remplis mon verre rythme en faisant ça
non non pas du tout il ya ce truc un peu
de pudeur aussi leur compte et en soirée
avec des gens que tu connais pas tu as
été protégé partons vers moi je suis la
meuf qui prennent a fait du buffet
physiquement parlant ouais mais battus
et moi toujours je me bats sur une
soirée 100 être protégé soit par un
petit truc que je bouffe soit par mon
verre régulièrement j'ai pris deux
scooters moi je les enlève ça chez soi
pas c'est comment tu fais pour aimer ça
ben justement le pire c'est que j'aime
parce qu'il y en a un qui est dit allez
on fait des shooteurs il a commencé à
servir tout le monde en fait j'ai suivi
le groupe quoi tu as
envie de vraiment cette pression sociale
dans notre consommation en fait ce qui
fait qu'ils te resterait du coup cinq
verres d'alcool sur ta semaine et là on
est largement d'ailleurs en dessous des
repères c'est intéressant de se dire que
quand on prend encore une fois sans se
culpabiliser de quoi que ce soit
jusqu'au on essaye de prendre conscience
de sa propre consommation au final
pire que cinq unités c'est que je me
prive de rien contre ça oui c'est ça ben
oui c'est ça que l'exercice vous le
voyez chacun a fait des efforts
incroyables mais reste encore légèrement
au dessus des repères par exemple audrey
a supprimé 1 de sévères mais il ya
toujours une journée où elle boit plus
de deux unités d'alcool fans y en a
aussi enlevé quelques uns bravo l
pourtant la journée à 4 unités de
l'empêchent de valider ce repère enfin
nino a été le plus spectaculaire dans
l'annulation de sévères même s'il reste
un peu au dessus là les billets presque
bravo quand même parce qu'eux aussi
aient un rapport avec l'alcool qui est
est ce que tu renvoies à l'autre demain
je vais boire un verre avec un pote je
vais prendre une bière je vais boire un
verre avec une meuf un dijk je vais
prendre un verre de vin blanc je vais
boire un verre avec mes parents je vais
prendre un soda le truc qu'on pourra
retenir c'est l'automatisme du quotidien
du cerveau de la routine de la routine
social qui fait que ce nombre de verres
d'alcool alors que l'alcool c'est pas
quelque chose à diaboliser ce n'est pas
le but de cette vidéo mais par contre
c'est pas quelque chose d'anodin en fait
la grève est donc en cassant les
automatismes de consommation on prend du
recul et on peut se dire ah ok c'est
comme ça que je consomme peut-être que
je pourrai consommer différemment après
tout ces verts éliminés on pourrait
quand même se demander pourquoi ils ont
été consommés si facilement la réponse
est majoritairement la pression sociale
vous l'avez vu soyons lucides il est
très compliqué de refuser un verre
surtout qu'on a l'impression de se faire
juger et qu'en plus bas on se prend vite
une petite réflexion pas souvent
agréable c'est très courant d'entendre à
1 mais pourquoi tu es enceinte ou encore
un désole un loin mais je ne traite pas
avec de l'eau non ou encore le fameux a
fait pas ton rôle ou bois un vrai truc
houas a un problème avec l'alcool toi ou
encore même le naïf bah pourquoi c'est
pas toi qui conduis pourtant donnons le
choix de la boisson pour inciter ceux
qui ne veulent pas de verre ou d'un
autre vers apprendre autre chose qu'un
verre d'eau même si au demeurant il n'y
a pas mieux pour s'hydrater la bonne
parade pour les petites phrases sur le
fait de pas prendre un verre d'alcool
c'est d'abord de ne pas s'excuser
personnellement je vois pas souvent
d'alcool et quand on me propose un verre
et qu'on me demande pourquoi je veux pas
le boire je réponds les phrases
suivantes j'en ai pas envie tout
simplement vous avez vu le tout
simplement c'est imparable et en plus
c'est loin d'être sec comme réponse une
autre réponse peut être avenant j'ai
plutôt soif je vais plutôt prendre un
vrai vert j'adore dire un vrai vert pour
parler d'autre chose que de l'alcool et
de la même manière n'hésitez pas à
intervenir en toute bienveillance pour
aussi appuyé positivement quelqu'un qui
refuse un verre mais à qui on fait une
remarque c'est important de casser les
rituels de la consommation d'alcool
automatique et ça ça se joue en
collectif et encore une fois ne vous
sentez pas obligés et encore moins
désolé de refuser vous avez encore le
droit de décider de ce qu'ils rendent
dans votre organisme merci à toutes et à
tous d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au
bout et là je prend pas trop de risque
vraiment parce que s'ils sont encore là
c'est qu'ils sont jusqu'au bout c'est un
truc de mentalisme mais en vrai jespere
que le fait d'avoir vécu ça pour vous
comme pour nous ça ça va nous permettre
de nous aider peut-être a laissé un peu
moins son cerveau en mode automatique de
se poser pour se dire tiens est ce que
j'ai vraiment conscience de telles
décisions hôtel décision que je suis en
train de prendre ou est ce qu'elle se
fait un petit peu je me sens moi j'ai
envie de vous proposer de fêter oui
c'est un tournage avec des quelques jus
et quelques cocktails mais le tout sans
alcool parce que enfin c'est très bon et
puis ça désaltère donc ça fait plus
parce que de bon état juste
c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
ting tings alors merci merci beaucoup
dans les yeux merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je serais très
curieux qu'on échange dans les
commentaires sur ce que vous a inspiré
le fait de prendre conscience de sa
propre consommation attention on fait ça
sans pression d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas
de cliquer cette vidéo que je vous
invite à partager autour de vous merci
également à santé publique france de
m'avoir permis de réaliser ce format
cette expérience cette vidéo et merci
également à mes quatre invités d'avoir
participé comme je vous l ai dit tout à
l'heure vous trouverez leurs chaînes
leur instinct ce genre de détails dans
la description sinon moi je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard ça n'a pas
changé vous pouvez vous abonner en
cliquant ici c'est gratuit et à côté
vous trouverez deux autres vidéos sur le
cerveau un matière grise sur les super
pouvoirs qu'on a ici et un autre sur les
biais cognitif prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt ciao